[Musique]
non
y a qu'à voir les comptes non seulement
des usagers mais des gens qui
travaillent au ppt énormément de compte
à découvert des interdictions bancaires
qui se font des saisies sur salaire
parce qu on peut plus jouer dans les
deux bouts exploitation familiale
aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi exactement
ça se traduit comment dans les fonds
dans les faits l'exploitation familiale
c'est une exploitation entretenu et qui
fonctionne avec en général un couple
d'agriculteurs on se paye vraiment
maximum 5 500 mille francs de centimes
par mois pour les responsabilités que
nous avons le temps d'envoyer
aujourd'hui 5000 francs d'aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment le minimum pour vivre
décemment
actuellement je suis à la recherche d'un
emploi malheureusement marie bat
également et c'est bien c'est bien dans
les assedic
ils m'ont fait tout un dossier on a déjà
attendu deux mois et demi avant d'avoir
obtenu des indemnisations qui vont
bientôt hélas finir moi dans trois mois
je vais arriver en fin de droits et mon
mari au mois de juin également obligé de
serrer un peu la ceinture quoi comment
ça se passe sur est la ceinture non on
fait attention à ce qu'il faut acheter
pour manger et souvent c'est des trucs
qui coûte le moins cher
on essaye de trouver les que la
nourriture la nourriture qu'ils essaient
de temps en temps parce que les enfants
ont besoin de matériel pour l'école ça
marche bien à l'école mais ils ont un
peu des difficultés parce que vont il
sent que le problème qu'il ya dans la
maison et je crois que ces salons ça
leur apporte beaucoup sur leur ville en
dise colère le nord chose leur attitude
scolaire et s'il ya des problèmes de
santé
comment ça se passe bien on essaie de se
débrouiller quand même moi des fois je
donne si les enfants sont rue mais tout
ça dès du lait chaud du miel pour éviter
quand même c'est revenir médecin parce
qu'il ya des fois on coupa il est
scandaleux que des efforts soient
demandés à des malades qui sont pris à
100%
il est anormal de faire payer à des gens
âgés une part de leur traitement
je ne suis pas communiste mais je pense
qu'il est du devoir des médecins
travaillant dans le secteur public au
privé de dia à 7h aussi exactement ce
qu'il pense de ces problèmes
nous on nous fait mourir parce que soit
disant il ya un surplus de produits est
juste à côté il ya des gens qui meurent
parce qu'ils n'ont rien à manger
vous avez entendu andré lajoinie cette
phrase terrible
ceux qui n'ont rien à manger comment
aurait-on pu imaginer qu'on en arrive là
dans un des pays les plus riches du
monde le nôtre et à la veille de l'an
c'est inacceptable et même si on est pas
tous chez soi même par la porte et il y
a la croissance du chômage
il y a ceux qui aiment qu'on appelle
maintenant en fin de droit à deux
siècles après la révolution
mais cela n'est pas venu par hasard
c'est le résultat d'une politique
voilà des années des années quand même
la politique d'austérité c'est dur
giscard barre chirac mitterrand a pris
82 de nouveaux chirac
on a dit aux français il faut faire des
sacrifices il faut se serrer la ceinture
il faut de la précarité il faut donner
aux patrons la liberté de licenciés et
ça ira demi on embauchera et bien non ça
va plus mal ça va plus mal mais il y en
a qui disent que au fond c'est le prix
un prix terrible mais c'est le prix à
payer pour sortir la france de l'ornière
c'est faux puisque ça va mal pour la
majorité des gens c'est le fiasco mais
ça va mal pour la france puisque la
france dans le déclin sur toutes les
grandes questions qui caractérise un
pays développés formation
investissements emplois
combien ses supérieurs la france est
dans le déclin alors si je comprends
bien tout va mal pour tout le monde en
france
ah non pas pour tout le monde car les
les grandes fortunes en vue de kiplay le
patrimoine y compris quand elles payer
l'impôt symbolique sur le revenu les
profits ont doublé les capitaux qui vont
dans la spéculation ont été multipliées
par cinq
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
ce sont les pays qui ont les coûts
salariaux les plus élevés plus élevés
que ceux de la france qui nous enfoncent
ce qui veut dire qu'on a menti quand on
a dit aux français il faut se serrer la
ceinture et ça ira mieux
ça a été un ans aujourd'hui l'expérience
le montre
mais est ce que on ne peut pas penser
que c'est un mauvais mot
passé et que ce mauvais moment est
derrière nous c'est à dire qu'il est
passé je ne crois pas je crois que le
pire est devant nous le pire de nos
d'ailleurs les instituts de prévision de
on parle de 4 millions de chômeurs à
l'horizon 90 c'est à dire demain si on
laissait faire
oui le pire est devant nous alors andré
lajoinie on parle beaucoup de l'europe
et vous êtes contre l'europe alors
j'aimerais que vous expliquer aux
téléspectateurs en prenant des exemples
concrets et précis pourquoi je te contre
l'euro à ne sommes pas contre l'europe
le rappel d'une réalité géographique
nous sommes pour la coopération la plus
large au sein de l'europe des 12 et au
sein de l'europe continentale ses dires
du continent européen
mais l'europe il faut la juger sur pièce
d'abord le marché commun il existe
depuis 30 ans et que vont-ils faire
aujourd'hui
que va-t-il faire ils veulent aggraver
la situation c'est vous qui veulent
mettre un million de des tas de bonnes
terres agricoles en friche n'exagérez
pas là c'est une décision c'est une
décision un million d'hectares en friche
alors que les gens se privent de
nourriture en france et que quarante
mille enfants meurent de faim chaque
jour dans le monde
ils s'arrêtent ils ne s'arrêteront pas
là ils veulent donner la libre
circulation des capitaux
ça c'est la liberté comme la liberté du
renard dans le poulailler
ça va être les op 1 qui est existe
aujourd'hui qui font passer des pans
entiers de notre économie sous le
contrôle étranger ça va être les op à la
puissance 10 et ils veulent s'attaquer
aux statuts tous les travailleurs qui
dispose d'un statut de servir de
garanties pour leur emploi pour leur
retraite restreint ils veulent s'y
attaquer les rabaisser et vous pensez
donc que les travailleurs n'ont rien à
gagner à part d'un ces projets là les
travailleurs ont à gagner dans une robe
de la coopération
les travailleurs ont à gagner d europe
des travailleurs par exemple les
métallos jce allemands viennent
d'obtenir de rabaisser la semaine de
travail à 36 135 diminution de pouvoir
d'achat comme nous le demandons en
france nous qui demandons la semaine dry
35 heures ça démissionne pouvoir d'achat
les salariés de fort de grande bretagne
viennent d'obtenir des augmentations de
salaires les travailleurs des ptt en
france viennent de faire échec à la
menace de disloquer leur statut d'
privatiser les ptt bien ces salles
l'europe de l'avenir
l'europe des travailleurs mais pas
l'europe du capital m pourtant andré
lajoinie il suffit d'observer la vie
politique tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle sont d'accord
pour cette europe là ils sont même
d'accord pour beaucoup d'autres choses
oui ils ont une sorte de programme
commun au nom de l'europe de 92 se
disputent d'ailleurs la paire ternie t
de cet objectif
et ils veulent la politique d'austérité
il veut le surarmement et ils veulent
finalement gouverner ensemble
le président de la république ne s'en
cache pas il déclare vouloir former un
gouvernement avec des hommes de droite
s'appuyant sur des députés de droite et
bien dans l'histoire il faut le savoir
les français doivent le savoir il n'y a
jamais eu dans l'histoire du
gouvernement avec des hommes de droite
s'appuyant sur des députés de droite qui
est fait une politique de gauche et ça
n'existera jamais mais comment empêcher
alors cette éventualité bien le seul
moyen c'est de voter pour le parti
communiste pour le candidat communiste
24 ah oui ça sera dire non à la fois
cette politique d'austérité et dire oui
une véritable politique gauche et non à
ses alliances et ça sera le vote utile
les gens qui s'interrogent qui se
demande comment je peux voter pour moi
pour mes objectifs pour avoir du travail
oit brami leur salaire pour avoir le
smic à 6000 francs pour avoir des moyens
pour l'école et je suis le seul à
proposer 40 briard de d'économies à
faire sur le budget du ser armements à
le retrouver l'école précisément de
l'avenue je vous interromps là on va
regarder ensemble aux téléspectateurs
quelques images cependant très peu de
temps le 25 mai 1968 8 millions de
travailleurs sont en grève
ils obtiendront en particulier une
augmentation de 35 % du smic et la
reconnaissance de nouveaux droits
syndicaux aux élections législatives qui
suivent le parti communiste français
recueille 20 % des suffrages exprimés
on a eu le statut des fonctionnaires à
1947 parce que le parti communiste
faisait 25 points 5
on a eu la sécurité sociale 45 parce que
le parti communiste et on a toujours
quelque chose quand le parti communiste
est fort 1987 dit syndicalistes de chez
renault inculpés qui s'attaquent à l'om
s'attaquent aux familles car
effectivement en essayant de salir
l'individu servir le syndicat de manière
à nous faire passer pour des gens pour
des moins que rien il y a deux ans au
niveau syndical les gens nous ont
demandé de les soutenir dans une lutte
qu'ils avaient vis-à-vis des crédit
agricole qui voulait liquider tout leur
capital d'exploitation c'est-à-dire en
fait supprimer leurs droits vivaient
leur droit au travail de crédit agricole
a porté plainte pour entrave à la
liberté d'enchères ce qui fait qu'on ait
un certain nombre de syndicalistes
on est passé en correctionnelle comme
deux inculpés comme de vulgaires voleurs
le numéro deux du cnpf shota il dit
confondues pas la politique de la france
avec un parti communiste à 10% comme à
vienne pour ça et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec lui
nous amenons une bataille sur le smig
assimilés on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui une
bataille a porté ses fruits
par exemple à 84 la région pris la
direction du syndicat
il y avait un écart de près de 1000
francs entre les hommes et les femmes
qui est réduit aujourd'hui 1 500 francs
les on avait des gens comme des
tourneurs qui n'avait pratiquement
jamais de promotion vous avez
d'augmentation de salaire les soudeurs
pareil
les personnes aussi ces gens c'est qu'on
pourra faire à part par s'aperçoit
depuis quelques temps il ya un train
parce que t'es fait même si ça nous est
pas annoncé officiellement s'aperçoit
quand on fait le point fait les choses
qui bougent nation de nous accorder une
prime d'assiduité 200 francs par mois
pour l'ensemble du personnel
un rattrapage de 5% sur l'ensemble des
primes et des augmentations de salaires
pour de 2 5% pour l'année contre 88
il n'y a pas eu de grands mouvements il
ya eu des bons et des pétitions il ya eu
des arrêts de travail et l'arrêt de
travail qui n'ont guère dépasser une
heure mais ils ont été répétés plusieurs
fois avec une délégation la dernière
fois la direction ou des gens des
personnels qu'ils n'avaient jamais
participé à aucune négociation et la
direction
ah c'était le voeu de m'accompagner pour
venir poser les problèmes succès chez
revenus
victoire pour claveau
pour pierre andré albertini ça vaut la
peine
andré lajoinie un mot au fond résume le
la philosophie de ces images c'est que
le parti communiste est utile à la
société
tout à fait je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
il est il a été utile dans l'histoire on
pourrait rappeler le front populaire
c'est grâce à la position du parti
communiste et à la lutte qu'il a animée
qu'on a gagné congés payés
l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation des produits agricoles
pour les paysans et amis de même plus
récemment en 1968
nous avons grâce à l'action des
communistes nous avons gagné une
augmentation du smic de 30 5% mais c'est
valable aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les communistes où les jours
sont utiles efficaces pour les gens ils
sont contre les expulsions il lutte
contre les expulsions ils sont en train
aujourd'hui tous les jours dans les
dents les assedic avec les chômeurs en
fin de droits comme on dit pour arracher
des aides qui leur sont refusés parce
que les assedic préfèrent économiser cet
argent pour faire pour faire économiser
2 des cotisations au patronat via les
communistes sont à leurs côtés
voilà pourquoi le 24 avril voter
communiste et donner encore plus de
force à cette action des communes alors
on réagit ni une question directe au
fond qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire je
dirais personnellement à à cette immense
foule des électeurs qui ont la gauche au
coeur et qui sont inquiets sur l'avenir
de la gauche bien je sais que beaucoup
de gens qui ont des difficultés qu'ils
subissent ils sont victimes de cette
politique que je viens de rappeler
victimes pour eux victimes pour l'avenir
de leurs enfants victimes et qu'on paie
préoccupé par cette dégradation du poids
de la france préoccupée par ce déclin de
la france
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
actuellement très préoccupé il ya les
gens qui ont la gorge auteurs
c'est à dire qu'ils qui ne veulent pas
voir élu ni bar ni chirac
je redis c'est au 2e tour que vous
pourrez leur barrer la route
ce sera la sphère du deuxième tour
pourrait le faire au 2e tour mais je le
redis
apprenez à vous servir de cette élection
à deux tours
car cette élection à deux tours il ya le
deuxième tour il ya le premier est bien
le premier on peut et il faut
et c'est pour cela il faut exprimer la
politique qu'on veut voir suivre dans ce
pays c'est à dire a exprimé à la fois à
ce refus de cette politique d'austérité
de course aux armements d'atteintes aux
libertés quand on a vu les attaques
contre les militants syndicaux mais
aussi il faut exprimer la volonté d'une
autre politique une politique de justice
de liberté de paix que je propose est
d'ailleurs jambes je vais l'occasion d'y
revenir dans ses émissions officielles
où j'ai figuré les mes propositions dans
le programme que je défende qui est un
programme qui est un programme précis
élaboré par les communistes et par tous
ceux qui sont les amis n'ont pas pâti
tout ce qu'ils veulent donner leurs amis
mais je voudrais dire à celles et à ceux
qui sont donc préoccupés qu'ils ont la
gauche au coeur je voulais leur dire
vous pouvez au premier tour en votant
andré lajoinie de 24 avril le 24 avril
vous pouvez vous faire entendre vous
pouvez poser si vous êtes des millions à
peser dans ce sens là soyez sûr que ça
pèsera ça comptera après les élections
quel que soit le président élu et vous
direz vous direz avec ce vote la joie ni
nous voulons autre chose que cette
politique qui enfonce le peuple dans les
difficultés
nous voulons une véritable politique de
gauche et bien si tous ensemble nous
faisons cela si nous nous rassemblons
quelles que soient nos opinions nos
options philosophiques et bien nous
feront renaître l'espoir dans ce pays
[Musique]